bom primeiramente quero pedir licença
ancestralidade para que eu possa falar
nada do que eu digo aqui foi
exclusivamente produzido por mim nós não
inventamos a roda do conhecimento só
permitirmos com essa roda dos saberes
não pare de girar e pedi licença para
apresentar um conhecimento nos leva a
perguntar onde vive a tua ancestralidade
o páreo pendência respire se ouça e
sinta esse pode ser um desses momentos
desses limites que nos faz repensar
sobre a nossa própria existência nessa
sociedade quase não falamos sobre isso a
maioria das pessoas não têm interesse e
acham que desconhecem a sua mas pensar
sobre ancestralidade é respirar a vida o
significado segundo dicionário é
particularidade ou estado do que a
ancestral mas não é por essa definição
que busco para alcançar a compreensão do
que é a ancestralidade faz alguns anos
que mergulhei na pergunta que fiz ao
chegar aqui onde vive a ancestralidade e
o que eu descobri eu conto agora na
verdade ela vive em mais lugares do que
se pode contar
é mas dentro do que fora mas na terra do
que no ar mas dentro de nós do que
qualquer outro lugar saber e reconhecer
a presença da ancestralidade pode ser um
caminho possível para repensar outros
modelos sociais e eliminar as diversas
violências que somos submetidos no
cotidiano quem sabe olhar para frente
espelhando nas experiências do passado
nos ajudará a recriar caminhos por
estrada já trilhados eu sou filósofa e
quando eu comecei a estudar filosofia
essa ciência que penso ser e como cê se
configura no mundo me dei conta que o
único caminho que existia para esse
pensamento partir de um olhar na qual
sua génese e não tinha relação nenhuma
comigo e de pessoas como eu que o
pensamento universal ele tinha as suas
limitações e pensava sempre dentro do
mesmo círculo no meu período final da
graduação eu passar
eu pude abandonar o curso ou abandonar o
curso justamente por não me ver
representada por esses ensino de
filosofia como eu disse algum tempo eu
venho me debruçando em pensar sentir e
repensar modelos de filosofia de vida
para romper com as realidades vigentes
que não dão conta de todos nós para
completo quero mostrar a vocês uma outra
forma de pensar o ser de pensar esse ser
de luz pensar há um ensinamento na
filosofia que médica inclina teus
ouvidos ouvir minhas palavras aplica teu
coração em compreendê-las esse
ensinamento é de um filósofo a memória
um filósofo que médico da 18ª dinastia
que mede é o nome original do egito
egito é uma nomeação grega
i can meet significa terra preta
comunidade preta e para compreender este
ensinamento é preciso se ouvir ouvir os
elementos que te constitui o vir esse
sentidos que te formam e jamais xingando
o vira si mesmo e compreender que está
desde o seu processo de gestação toda
criança informação na gestação recebe um
primeiro elemento é uma gota de sangue
na formação desse coração o coração era
chamado de ib um coração e um aspecto
metafísico que transmutam a mente em
seguida essa criança agora informação
recebe um ren o nome para sua
identificação em si em seguida recebemos
um sopro
o que constitui o nosso duplo a nossa
sombra um cheltin em seguida nós
recebemos uma energia de alinhamento
vital um elemento vital que em
consonância com o bar faz e constrói a
nossa alma esses são os cinco elementos
que constituem o indivíduo e é nessa
gota de sangue a partir da concepção que
no coração moram as nossas emoções e é
por elas que nós acessamos para pensar
sobre cada um de nós o coração é a
morada da nossa consciência nós somos
todos esses elementos que dialogam que
nos fazem que nos constrói nós somos um
ser e o ser ele é um todo o pensar que
médico é um exercício de ouvir a si
mesmo
e é daí que está o princípio da
ancestralidade todos nós carregamos uma
gota de sangue desse ancestral por essa
peça gota sempre recebe o sangue de quem
está gestando desde sempre a cada
geração novas vidas vão se formando ao
longo do tempo e o tempo se refazendo
algo fundamental a se compreender que
quando estamos falando de ancestralidade
não estamos necessariamente falando de
espiritualidade mas é em se tratando de
filosofia africana antiga filosofar
também é um exercício espiritual
espiritualidade algo divino e pleno para
as concepções africanas na unidade
cultural da áfrica ancestralidade e
espiritualidade são elementos que se
constituem mas independente de como nós
organizamos a nossa vida nós temos um
ancestral a
se alguém que nos antecedeu alguém que
nos trouxe até aqui alguém que faz parte
do nosso percurso de vida alguém que nos
faz potência alguém alguém precisamos
sempre voltar para andar à frente e como
nós percebemos essa presença
o nosso coração
ah entendeu porque eu pedi licença para
falar da ancestralidade porque eu estou
andando para frente olhando para trás no
pulsar da existência ancestral no pulsar
da minha mente alimentada pelo coração
cardiograph quando os meus saberes assim
matéria e espírito não se dicotomista
pra existir nós coexistimos pela
confluência da ancestralidade que
permanece viva e pulsa dentro de nós o
coração esse elemento vital que pulsa
pulsa e pulsa e joga o sangue o e já é
o que é o que nos constitui e faz com
que fiquemos em pé sentimentos nos fazem
potência caroline amanda paridor a
maioria das pretas uma prática
filosófica ancestral nos pergunta o que
o ventre do ventre do ventre do ventre
que te trouxe ao mundo pode dizer de
vocês agora esse ventre alimentado por
essa formação rega a nossa existência
regando a nossa potência em qualquer
momento da vida em qualquer prática de
movimentação quando estamos pensando com
o coração sentimentos faz com que
sejamos o que nós realmente somos
sentimos logo coexistimos e quando nos
movimentamos ouvindo o coração estamos
pensando e ouvindo a ancestralidade e é
isso que o ventre do mundo tem a nos
dizer é necessário romper
e violências nas quais somos submetidos
ao longo de todos os tratamentos que nos
foram impostas por que nós temos
ancestralidade e dentro de nós mora a
nossa possibilidade de avançar de nos
mover e quem sabe nos curar a nossa
ancestralidade ela não começa a partir
de uma corretamento ou de uma violência
física a nossa ancestralidade parte de
um momento na qual não existiam
correntes e também não existe alguém
acorrentava
é por isso que nós precisamos ouvir
exibir essa constituição de nós mesmos
para encontrar os ensinamentos que
existe dentro de cada um de nós para que
possamos compreender de fato quem e o
que nós somos e quanto nós fazemos esse
exercício chegamos ao que os antigos
filósofos africanos acreditavam que era
o equilíbrio a linearidade as duas
pontas de construção do sujeito então
como pensar a ancestralidade e refazer o
caminho para o futuro o que o vento
ancestral tem para te dizer nos passos
que serão trilhados daqui para frente de
todas as ciências que a áfrica produziu
os saberes que o médicos e eles são uma
partícula de vários dos diversos
elementos na universalidade do
continente africano
nós podemos pensar em outras ciências
nas tecnologias no conjunto de técnicas
e processos que morreram muito
grandiosas transformações no mundo e que
nem sequer são reconhecidas como
africanas respirar e respirar em
revisitar os modelos tecnológicos
ancestrais para pensar o ontem o hoje
caminhando para uma manhã esse é um
futuro e vocês como olham para o futuro
uma sugestão pode ser um olhar para o
futuro que nos obriga a fazer um retorno
sankofa um pássaro que caminha para
frente sempre olhando para trás e sendo
obrigados a fazer essa retomada
descobrimos que nós não somos melhor que
os nossos ancestrais e que os seus
valores e modos de produzir a vida a
tecnologia ancestral os ensinamentos
profundamente criados pelos nossos
ancestrais
e que tipo de ação nós precisamos tomar
para construir o futuro que nós queremos
entender quem fomos nos ajuda a entender
quem queremos ser tecnologias não se
astrais como sinaliza a morena mariah
são todos os modos de produzir a vida
que os nossos ancestrais nos deixaram
como legado saberes esses produzidos ao
mais diversos contextos exemplos são a
cura através das ervas a filosofia
africana a capoeira os ritos a música os
processos de aquilombamento no brasil o
parto natural aos terapias holísticas a
se o gás a oralidade e seus métodos a
escrita o culto aos antepassados os
exercícios de respiração e tantos outros
saberes que nos permitiram chegar até
aqui e nos mantiveram-se em pé até o
presente momento
o modelo de sociedade que pensa na
realidade das tecnologias vão cês traz
uma sociedade com um enorme avanço
tecnológico com valores galgados não
sexualidade uma ação comunitária que
caminha e produz mudanças e utiliza as
tecnologias vão cês tais como
ferramentas de transformação sem perder
o seu bombear e nem deixar de ouvir e
movimentar-se pelos modelos não se
astrais dá ao gado na comunidade como
vamos pensar um futuro na qual as
pessoas avancem com suas tecnologias
cada vez mais individualizantes sem
perder o nosso senso de humanidade
construindo grandes empreendimentos sem
esquecer que avançar sem estar ligado
com a sua comunidade não é uma avança
para ir mais longe com as asas da
tecnologia é preciso estar de mãos dadas
com a sua comunidade então eu ratifico
e onde vive a tua ancestralidade a minha
moro em mim no meu ib no meu coração em
minhas memórias eu sou uma mulher
nascida e criada dentro de um quilombo
trago esse exemplo porque falar de um
sensualidade a falar de mim falar das
tecnologias não se estais que nos
trouxeram até aqui e por essas
tecnologias de técnicas e lógicas
produzidas dentro de um quilombo na qual
eu nasci aí eu uma mulher preta
quilombola trouxe essa técnica de
recriar olhares para dentro da filosofia
um saber de reconstrução como saberes
que ao longo da vida eu aprendi e que
tinha um esse gingado pylon besta é
preciso uma aldeia inteira para educar
uma criança diz o provérbio africano eu
sou fruto desse saberes vão se estais
construídos no saber do quilombo eu sou
essa criança e eu falo desse lugar dos
saberes que
um banho e cardiografo nossas potências
em mim e por mim a ancestralidade ela
nunca nos abandona elas nunca deixam de
lado a em tudo quanto é lugar está em
tudo que é vivo no vento na
materialidade no chão e uma música e uma
poesia na filosofia na luta na natureza
no movimento de caminhar em cada um de
nós em cada pessoa que respira que se
organiza para pensar medidas efetivas de
combate à violência e se movimenta está
no amor está em mim que fiz o meu
primeiro vestibular aqui nessa
universidade porque a minha ancestral
direta que me deu a gota minha mãe sônia
ribeiro uma mulher preta incrível
militante formado em ciências sociais
por essa instituição que me fez e me
constituiu enquanto potência e me disse
é importante estar nesse lugar
e é importante trilhar esse caminho eu
ouvi com esse coração que pulsa e pulsa
e pulsa então
me pare pense e
e respire se ouçam e sintam a tua
ancestralidade está em todas aquelas e
aqueles que fizeram com que essa gota
chegassem até aqui e possibilitasse que
os seus os nossos bens nunca parasse de
bater é o que nós somos em essência
rotep axé
[Aplausos]